Hey everybody,
welcome to a little impromptu nerd,
writer q and a filmed on my new fisheye
iphone lends attachment,
which I'm really excited about.
I put on twitter for questions.
You guys put a lot of cool ones in
there.
So let's get right down to it at Daemen.
Five wants to know what is your research
process like?
Um,
so my research process has always been
the same and the way that it works is
when I pick a topic,
um,
and that's a whole nother story,
but when I finally choose one,
I kind of immersed myself in everything
that I could possibly read about it.
I read articles,
academic journals.
I got to log in from a Grad school
friend of mine.
They'll tell anybody,
uh,
and I,
I read as much as I can about it until I
feel sort of comfortable with the issue
that,
that I know everything.
And then I kind of let the structure of
what the video is going to be bubbled up
into my head.
That's always how it works.
Eventually I'll get to a point where the
structure of the video I say we'll just
become apparent.
I don't know why that is,
but it just happens.
And then I'll start to write a going on
from there,
you know,
either.
All right,
the whole script and then edit over it.
Um,
or all right.
The first part of it and think,
well,
I have to edit this to know what comes
next.
Once I edit this first part,
I'll see what the rhythm is like and
then I can write the next part of it.
So it depends on the topic and it
happens in different ways.
But,
um,
the research processes intensive,
I only have like a week or a couple of
weeks to do the research proper for a
video.
So I dive in heart at Devante wants to
know,
do you have a preferred Stanley Kubrick
film?
Um,
I'd have to say 2001.
A space odyssey at the rising tides
wants to know what tips do you have for
people looking to get into video essays
other than just start?
Um,
so he's referring to a tweet that I put
out recently where I said that so many
people will actually messaged me
everyday to say that they want to get
into this,
but they don't know where to start.
And my advice is the same for everybody.
It's just start.
And that might sound a little bit
reductive,
but it's really the best advice that I
could give.
You know,
so many people I know never get past the
idea phase or the conceptualizing phase
and what creative work requires is that
you make something,
finish it,
identify what you didn't like about it
and approve on it in the next one.
Youtube is unique and awesome for that
reason because I get to put a video out
every weekend and every week I look at
it and get a chance to improve a little
bit.
But if I had never put something out
there,
if I had delayed,
delayed until,
until the thing was perfect,
I never would have gotten to where I am
today.
You know,
the only important thing in the
beginning is that you're confident and
that you put something out there.
And then if you know somebody who is
trying to do this,
that you give them the encouragement to
actually start because that's the
hardest part.
Eventually you can give them
constructive criticism when they've
established themselves a little bit.
But in the beginning,
encouragement is key at neo too.
What John Wants to know.
Expanding beyond nerd writer,
what is your longterm goal?
That's a good question.
Now.
I love the Internet.
I love Youtube and I wouldn't rather be
doing anything else.
It's afforded me the opportunity to,
to have a career in which my creative
output is 100 percent mine.
They editorial control is 100 percent
mine.
No one else even works on the nerd
writer channel.
And that's really cool.
I mean,
I've talked to and had conference calls
about potential things and other kinds
of media,
which is exciting,
but I'm not totally sure that I want to
go those routes and give up the control
that I have here because that has gotten
to me,
were gotten me where I am today.
And people like the Vlog brothers who
have rejected,
uh,
opportunities in legacy media is a real.
I think,
um,
the real pioneers for people who want to
stay online at Mad Mozelle wants to know
how to find one's purpose in life,
stick to a thing or keep searching.
Now this is a huge question.
I'm probably not qualified to answer it,
but as far as purpose goes,
I think that there's a real tragedy
there,
which is that I think we're obviously
not given any kind of objective or
cosmic purpose.
I don't believe that.
I don't believe that that exists or that
you can find that,
but I think that even personally there
is nothing that there's no purpose that
you have that you don't choose.
That's kind of how it works.
You have to choose your purpose and that
choice is,
it's pretty much arbitrary.
People who say that they were born to do
this are born to do that.
I feel like either they're,
they don't know that they're lying to
themselves or there's a little bit of
self deception they are going on and
that's really hard.
If you come out of college and you don't
know what you want to do and you feel
like I,
I can't figure out what I want to do,
nothing,
it's just occurring to me.
It's because nothing will occur to you.
You just have to choose at.
Darren Robertson wants to know.
I've seen people write off your videos
as pretentious mostly because of how you
speak in them.
How do you feel about this?
I've seen those comments.
I probably am pretentious,
so I don't really have that much of a
response to that,
but you know,
as far as the way that I talk,
you know,
that's just the way that I talk.
I never ever tried to talk a certain
way.
People talk a lot about the pauses at
the end of my videos.
You know,
if you're an editor and you've edited
for a long time,
you learn to do things by instinct.
Then as far as those final lines in
every video go,
that's just the instinct of the rhythm
that I feel works.
So I,
I always just go by my editing instinct.
Um,
and you know,
I've,
I've paid more attention to it as more
people have brought it up and tried to
like make the pauses a little less.
Um,
but,
you know,
I'm just doing whatever I feel is right.
It's all I can do.
And uh,
you know,
any accusations of,
a lot of my favorite creators have been
called potential,
so I'm,
I'm pretty okay with being put in that
company at Ben Hawkes says,
what about a video of your impressions
on your trip to France last summer?
Why can't believe you remember that?
I did make a little video about that and
watch it here at Bryan spargo rights.
What do you think has been the biggest
tool for your growth and outreach?
Social media,
word of mouth or your own marketing?
The biggest tool for growth and outreach
for me has just been grinding out the
video's pushing through the times in
which nobody was watching in the
beginning and then the plateaus of not
much subscriber growth in the middle
because that,
that I think will happen to everybody,
but I try to make my headlines as good
as possible.
I sort of hate headlining,
I hate clickbait.
I try to do my best to,
to sort of walk the line of being not
too click Baity,
but being not too boring because now the
truth is people look at,
you know,
they look at a million links a day and
if you can't grab them a little bit with
your headline or your thumbnail,
they're not going to watch you.
So you think you have to be cognizant of
that.
And Hank Green actually wrote a great
article on medium where he talks about
how,
you know,
you shouldn't feel bad about clickbait
titles if the content you're giving them
as good work at j dot Williams.
Jay wants to know,
what are some of your favorite novels?
Um,
I,
I have to mention him.
John Harrison,
again,
I always mentioned he's my favorite
novelist.
And so,
so,
so obscure.
It's,
it's,
it's a,
it's a real tragedy and he's written a
science fiction and literary fiction.
But I suggest you start with the novel
light,
which is so good.
And I think you'll go on to read more of
his after you read that one.
I'm also,
I have to mention Lawrence Durrell,
who is,
um,
who wrote the Alexandria Quartet and the
Avignon quinten.
I've,
I've read most of what he's written also
kind of forgotten novelists,
but his sort of theories and treatments
of personality and friendship and
relationships form the kind of basis of
my philosophy of,
of relationships.
And I can't recommend him enough.
So check out Lawrence Darell really good
stuff that's stolen.
PVP wants to know which presidential
candidate seems competent this election
year.
I'm not going to get into who I support
officially,
but I do really want to recommend a
website called [inaudible] dot org,
um,
in which you are.com
and which you are given questions about
a lot of different issues and you're,
you're lined up with the candidate that
most represents your interests.
My sister who took it last week said
that everyone should be required to take
this little survey because I think
that's a big problem with democracy in
our country is that people don't vote
their interests.
They don't know,
you know,
on a granular level what candidate
supports what issue on what level.
And I think knowing those things would
help.
All of us had a break through the noise
and see who will actually represent us
the way we want to be represented at pip
head to says tips for young writers.
Yes,
write more.
I've written hundreds of thousands of
words since I started writing them.
In the beginning it was crap and I knew
it was crap and I hated it because like
Ira glass one said my tastes with so
much better.
I want it to be like the people I love,
but I couldn't achieve it.
If you write a lot,
I think you'll see improvement in your
writing way quicker than you think.
I mean,
it's not gonna happen overnight,
but improvement happens when you just
put the work in that uh,
Paul John Cannon wants to know,
would you ever consider touring slash
giving talks to promote your videos?
That's actually a great question because
I'm going to be giving my first Tedx
talk in Pennsylvania,
actually near my hometown at Lafayette
College next month.
And I'm really excited about that.
I'm going to be talking about video
essays and what they are.
So I think I will be doing more of this
moving forward and uh,
I just want to make sure that it's
great.
I want the speeches to be great.
So I'm going to be taking a week off,
I think this week that you're seeing
this too,
right?
That ted talk and make sure that it's
really good and up to snuff at social on
wants to know what is your setup,
what programs do you use?
I'm just quickly.
I use final cut pro 10 and then a lot of
people hate that program,
but Toni Jo at every frame convinced me
to use it and I actually really love it
now and I mean it does everything I need
it to do.
Oh,
and the mic that this is an old Mc and
people ask like,
why is it so beat up around here?
It's because fall off my desk a bunch of
times.
Um,
it's an old mike from best buy.
I can't,
I don't know if you can get any more,
but I really like the quality of it at
ballsy.
Wants to know who is your favorite
youtuber and who you get inspired by the
most.
Um,
so I just,
I'll split this question into two parts
really quickly.
First,
on a formal level,
a lot of people love him,
but Casey Neistat is a real inspiration
for me because I think he's doing
something that he's,
he's,
he's pioneering a style that is
completely unique to online video.
That's what I want to see more of.
And on a content level,
I love the video essays that box is
making right now.
I think there are sort of,
you know,
they're the most prestige video essays
from a corporation that I've seen.
I love New York Times.
Op Docs are too.
Also.
I really love every frame of painting
and Adam Westbrook's video essays at
[inaudible] Dot TV.
I'm,
I'll put some more in the description at
Calabasas or wants to know,
do like pancakes.
Yes.
Obviously Atlanta home age wants to
know,
what were you doing before youtube?
I might have answered this before,
but before,
directly,
before I was doing this full time,
was working at discovery discovery
digital network,
uh,
producing a show called secret daily,
which I wrote and hosted.
That was loosely,
very loosely based on the nerd writer.
Um,
they got me from MSNBC,
MSNBC got me from a video that I did a
while ago on the kind fund and then
before that I was just doing odd jobs
and I tell them marketed for car
warranties,
which was so horrible.
And then,
uh,
before that I was in school.
Um,
so it's been a wild ride since I
graduated and I'm glad I finally ended
up here working for myself,
not in an office because I hate offices
so much at Tilghman.
Trevor wants to know what do you make of
rotten tomatoes effect on modern day
film culture?
That's a great question.
I,
you know,
I always check rotten tomatoes before
going to see a movie just because I
don't want to spend $15 or $18 with
ticket prices so high on seeing an okay
movie.
I think the negative side of that is
that we lose the ability to see nuance
in our films and see the great things
and bad movies or see the bad things in
good movies,
but you know,
maybe I'll just see nuance when I can
watch it at home at Louis [inaudible] to
know in your opinion,
which is the best youtube video you
posted.
I really liked the video I did on
Rihanna and dance hall just because it
was a challenge to figure out how to
express those ideas visually and once I
hit on how to do it,
um,
I was really excited.
And what is the most fun for me is
experimenting with visual styles,
doing things that are new,
innovating,
always trying to push the envelope a
little bit to do something that people
haven't done before.
So that one I really loved.
I really loved my actually death with
dignity video.
I did.
I tried a lot of interesting things
there.
Anything that you see for me that is
experimental,
just know that I was having a lot of fun
making it silent.
But sure,
nine months to know if you were a song,
what song would you be?
I hope I'm doing a day in the life by
the Beatles because that's my favorite
song and I'd like to be my favorite song
at Souza.
Eduardo wants to know what's the role of
art and these postmodern filter bubble
internet days and how can we really
connect to each other?
Well that's not.
I love the term postmodern filter.
Bubble Internet days is a great for an
album or a book.
I think,
you know,
it's interesting question because art
clearly doesn't have the weight that it
used to have and there's never going to
be,
I think a dickens again,
but you know,
I could make something and the whole
world can see it.
It might be a little bit more fleeting
than a past works past novels or past
sort of mediums,
but you know,
it's a,
it's a whole new world and we have to
work with the Times that we have as far
as how do we really connect to each
other.
I mean got to just make friends and be
with people.
I mean,
you know,
Internet is great and I have a lot of
people who I communicate with you on the
Internet and people communicate with me
through my videos,
but my actual physical friendships and
relationships are the most important
thing to me in the world and we have to
cultivate those I think because it keeps
us grounded and I love those people.
I Love My friends at Collin mx 31 wants
to know,
do you work off a template or have a
formula of some sort?
No,
I don't have a template and it would be
no fun for me at all if I did.
I mean that's part of the reason why I
left discovery digital networks because
the strictures of producing one video a
day meant that I then everything had to
be templatized.
The editor is only had half a day to
work on it,
so everything had to look the same every
day and we sort of slotted as script
into this be rolled formula.
That just wasn't interesting to me.
I think every piece of content has to be
mapped with a form that is unique to it.
At vague solutions wants to know what's
the way to your heart?
Well,
you should probably ask my girlfriend
about that.
The amazing,
incredible Lisette Videa who hosts d
news.
She is the love of my life.
I couldn't possibly love anyone more.
And she's talented and beautiful and
funny and weird like me in all those
ways.
Um,
so check out her stuff.
I'll link it here.
I love you at Citizen Austin.
One wants to know,
are there any films you could consider
it to be flawless of two films,
the big Lebowski and hot fuzz that keep
calm,
read and wants to know.
I read your book,
Big City and loved it and he plans on
reading any more novels.
So I thank you for reading big city.
I sort of cringe when I read that now.
Um,
I wrote two novels that,
and another one which I never put out,
which I cringe even more to read,
but I,
I,
you know,
I love fiction.
I just think I love this a little more
and I knew that as I was starting this
channel as learning that.
And um,
I have a third book that I'm writing now
which is hard side pie and it's so cool,
but I just don't have the time.
If you've written a novel,
you know that you have to really devote
all your time to it because you have to
sort of stay in the story in your mind.
I don't have the time to do that now.
Hopefully sometime in the future.
I'd love for you guys to read it.
I was thinking about like putting it
out,
putting it out chapter by chapter and
letting you guys read it.
What,
what do you think about that?
Let me know in the comments.
Yeah.
Jay Sean wants to know how do you feel
about Internet memes?
Just quickly,
I'd like to say that I love Internet
memes and nothing makes me laugh harder
than some of the jokes on imager.
I don't know what it is.
It's like a whole new form of ultra
aggressive comedy that has ruined me for
a lot of other kinds of comedy.
And finally at Joseph Wallace wants to
know what are the key components of a
great video essay?
How do you make people care about
something they didn't know before?
Um,
so this is,
this is really my job and I think the
most important thing is that you develop
a narrative,
uh,
about a,
about a topic,
about an issue,
you know,
you can present facts and information,
but I think people really latch onto
stories and that's what I try to do with
every video.
You know,
this is a metaphor that I love,
which is that I'm on film sets.
When you're a lighting them,
you know,
the way that it looks on the set has
nothing,
you know,
it doesn't look anything like the way
that it looks when you see it on film,
but gaffers and directors of photography
know how that sort of weird code of how
to light something on a set to make it
look a certain way.
You just have to practice and know it.
And I think when I'm doing a video essay
on something,
what I'm trying to do is create a kind
of all chemical reaction in the story
that I'm telling that makes you as
inspired about this thing as I am.
Like I said before,
these are primers and essays,
which means they're short.
So I hope that I've inspired you enough,
like the greatest teachers I've had to
go out and learn more about it.
Um,
so I think narrative story is the most
important thing.
Getting people engaged in something that
they wouldn't have thought they could
have liked before.
Okay.
That was so much fun.
Thank you for asking your questions.
I really appreciated all the questions
you put in there.
Um,
I'm not that great of an extemporaneous
talker of the nerdwriter is all about
sort of writing and articulating the way
that I feel about something before
presenting it.
So that's the way I like to communicate
normally,
but I think this is a good opportunity
to put a,
put a lot of things on record about how
I feel about stuff and,
and,
and I appreciate your interest always.
Thank you so much for watching.
Thank you for continuing to watch.
I am working my ass off here to make the
best possible video is for you that I
can.
Um,
and uh,
and yeah,
I'll see you for the next video.